donc
mexicana c'est la boisson qui est à côté
de toi le slogan c'est mexicana la
fraîcheur du Mexique que vous souhaite
une bonne soirée donc tu prends la
bouteille toute la bouteille tu te sers
un verre tu bois et tu dis le Sogan
après d'accord ok mexicana fraîcheur du
Mexique vous souhaite une bonne soirée
c'est parti top s'il vous plaît
je veux pas ouvrir la bouteille tu veux
pas non c'est pas que je veux pas c'est
que j'y arrive pas
d'accord ok
bon on va changer la bouteille alors
s'il vous plaît c'est pas possible ça
d'avoir une bouteille qui s'ouvre pas
comme ça s'il vous plaît voilà
mexicana la fraîcheur du Mexique vous
souhaite une bonne soirée
souhaite une bonne soirée c'est parfait
tout de suite
attention ah pardon j'ai pas dit top
c'est de ma faute c'est de ma faute
c'est de ma faute pardon pardon pardon
pardon pardon pardon excusez-moi
la fraîcheur du Mexique vous souhaite
une bonne soirée
je peux pas voir ça vous avez goûté
je suis désolé mais c'est tu bois pas
quoi tu vois c'est Amazon
[Musique]
que tu fais là quand tu bois comme ça
quoi tu vois
la fraîcheur du Mexique c'est ça quoi
juste après que la glotte descende quoi
mexicains
une bonne gorgée allez on y va
mexicana la fraîcheur du Mexique vous
souhaite une bonne soirée
[Musique]
on souhaite une bonne soirée
fraîcheur du Mexique vous souhaite une
bonne soirée
la fraîcheur du Mexique vous souhaite
une bonne soirée
faut mettre plus de vraiment tu peux
t'écarter un petit peu on va faire le
raccord vite coiffure la mèche s'il te
plaît
mexicana on va le refaire tout de suite
la fraîcheur du Mexique où c'est une
bonne soirée ça sauf que ce qui serait
bien c'est de le faire sans le
selon
tu as une crotte pardon juste excuse-moi
mais tu as juste une crotte là quoi on
peut l'aider quelqu'un mexicana la
fraîcheur du Mexique vous souhaite une
bonne soirée mexicana la fraîcheur du
Mexique vous souhaite une bonne soirée
mexicanal la fraîcheur du Mexique vous
souhaite une bonne soirée oui c'était un
peu parlant
du Mexique
et bienvenue à une caméra cachée de mon
ami Pascal c'est
[Musique]